after decades our Freddy Krueger movies
it's easy to forget where this killer
came from and why he became so iconic so
we're taking a deep dive into the man
behind the third-degree burns from his
monstrous conception to his showdown
with Jason he is Freddy Krueger's back
story explained things were never going
to be easy for Frederick Charles Krueger
as chronicled in a Nightmare on Elm
Street 3 dream warriors his mother
Amanda Krueger was better known by her
chosen name sister Mary Helena
[Music]
as an urn she worked at the Hathaway
house an asylum for the criminally
deranged a few days before Christmas
1941 Amanda found herself the victim of
a mix-up she was locked inside the
building when the guards went home for
the long weekend leaving the
high-security hospital and attended by
the time she was found she'd suffered a
series of horrendous attacks at the
hands of the inmates and was pregnant
with the best concern of a hundred my
months later a bouncing baby Freddy was
born
never want to catch a break he was
adopted by an abusive alcoholic named
mr. Underwood what followed was
predictably sort of a huge nightmare
understandably Freddy was a troubled
child his adopted dad was drunk all the
time and seemed to take a great deal of
joy in beating his young Ward with a
belt at school Freddy was taunted
mercilessly for his heritage
he started to exhibit the tell-tale
signs of a fictional serial killer
killing the class hamster and getting a
kick out of cursing himself with a
straight razor
sadly young Frederick never experienced
a personal metamorphosis and one
particularly unfortunate day and able to
sum up the constant tirade of abuse from
his adoptive dad Freddie jammed his
razor blade deep into the eye socket of
his father figure it could be argued
that this was where any hopes of a happy
life died and the Springwood slasher was
born the events of Freddie's young adult
life a murky and it's not clear whether
or not he ever faced any legal
consequences for killing mr. Underwood
what's his known is up by his mid-20s
Fred Krueger was in the family way he'd
married a woman named Loretta who gave
birth to a daughter Catherine together
they lived what was to the casual
observer a simple happy family life
lying just beneath the surface however
was a dark secret
Freddie unable to stem is unquenchable
bloodlust had constructed a secret room
in the family's suburban home inside he
kept a series of homemade weapons
newspaper clippings and memorabilia from
his off-hours hobby which was
slaughtering the children of Springwood
Ohio as a mysterious killer known as the
spring wood slasher
I took all their Shu marriages if
nothing else based on trust and the
Kruegers home life hit a speed bump when
the Reta discovered Freddy's McCobb
mancave
Freddy killed his wife in front of their
young daughter was arrested for the
deaths of numerous local children and
Katherine was put into foster care under
a new name the arrest and subsequent
trial of Fred Krueger sparks high
tempers and the good folks of spring
wood the evidence condemning the spring
wood slasher was damning and justice for
the roughly two dozen children who died
by his benign hand lay on the line
unfortunately thanks for misplaced
signature and the drunken judge Krueger
was set free despite clearly being
guilty famous but somebody forgot to
sign a search warrant in the right place
and conquer was free just like that the
parents of spring would however were
less than inclined to follow suit the
good folks of spring would fond an
old-fashioned vigilante mob trapping
Fred and soaking him in gasoline before
lighting him on fire little did they
know that as they watched the building
burn to the ground
Krueger was being approached by dream
demons these supernatural entities
offered Krueger the opportunity to carry
on his sadistic ways indefinitely as
they otherworldly antagonistic agent
Krueger became a denizen of the dream
realm a plane of existence where human
subconscious thought takes place while
there he had the ability to manipulate
reality and effect unconscious humans as
long as he was still remembered and
feared in the real world his control
over the dreamworld seemed just about
unlimited he could change his shape move
objects telepathically and warped the
physical manifestations of tremors
additionally any damage that Freddy
course in a dream also happened in the
real world blended into a geyser of
blood and viscera in your nightmare your
parents are in for a double dose of
tragedy as your death goes unexplained
and then never to resell your otherwise
lightly used mattress being on the dream
demon payroll has plenty of pluses but
it's not without some downsides for one
you're pretty well stuck in the dream
realm a supernatural blend of the
collective unconscious be entering the
physical plane leads to nothing but
trouble for mr. Krueger who becomes
susceptible to pain and even death
[Music]
in the meantime life in the dream realm
can be every bit as frustrating
generally speaking Freddie can only
consume the souls of the residents of
Springwood barring gout side
intervention even then the powers only
work on the good folks of spring would
Harbor a healthy level of active fear
regarding Elm streets favorite burn
victim if nobody remembers Freddie he's
nothing more than a bad dream 13 years
after his unholy baptism by fire Freddie
made his first known appearance in the
form we've all come to know and lose
sleep over no Nightmare on Elm Street
with a sick new menagerie of super
powers he began to haunt the dreams of
the children of Springwood with
vengeance for his death and skullduggery
in his heart he got down to the business
of gruesome child killing the firsts ago
was Tina who started off the story
proper with a bad dream about a
disfigured claw handed man pursuing her
through a boiler room Tina made the
age-old mistake of being a romantically
active teenager in a horror film and she
paid for it in the form of a dream world
glove slashing Freddie would go on to
drop Rod Tina's boyfriend with a Swiss
strangulation as well as Glen a hero
Nancy's beau
Nancy meanwhile managed to be back the
nefarious killer using nothing but her
wits on her well I take back every bit
of energy I gave you
[Music]
you're nothing oh did she at the end of
the film she certainly seemed to lose
alt while Kruger played evil Knight
Rider if the ending of a Nightmare on
Elm Street was strange the entirety of A
Nightmare on Elm Street to Freddy's
revenge was on a whole different level
the rules that had held sway in the
first film disappeared and Freddy became
a little nest tree monster and for one
brief entry in the franchise a little
more of a metaphor for repressed
romantic feelings between teenage boys
something is trying to get inside my
body
yeah she's female and she's waiting for
you in the Cabana and you want to sleep
with me the main character jesse was an
adolescent boy who moved into Nancy's
old house on Elm Street
rather than haunting the kids dreams
Krueger was straight to possess a lad
eventually taking over his body and
physically manifesting in his burn to
perform the forces of something
eventually won the day and Freddie was
sent back to the unconscious realm it's
certainly a cult classic but not
necessarily a classic classic freddie
was back to his old shenanigans in a
Nightmare on Elm Street three dream
warriors all of the children of Elm
Street had either been killed or driven
mad with the survivors living together
in an asylum only there was a twist the
residents of the asylum were brought
together by none other than Nancy
Thompson from the first movie now
working in the hospital while
researching dreams for graduate school
one of the patients young Kristen Parker
had the ability to pull other people
into her dreams but the folks inside
were granted superpowers
[Applause]
Fredy it's earned out could be defeated
if his bones were buried and sanctified
which was something that good guys
learned from the ghosts of his dead
mother
Freddie wound up down for the count
thanks to a hasty burial and nobody ever
heard from him again only they did a
Nightmare on Elm Street for the tree
master saw Freddie's return as Nightmare
on Elm Street sequels usually do here he
bounced back in a big way and put down
all those pesky kids from dream warriors
like he was living some scooby-doo
villains power fantasy he was taken down
by Alice Johnson a teenage sleep Messiah
and quote dream master capable of
manipulating good dreams away Freddy
controlled the bad how do you handle
your nightmares my mom taught me when I
was little did you ever hear at the
dream master but you can't keep a good
son of a hundred maniacs down and Freddy
confusingly birth himself from the
spirit of his dead mother in the fifth
film the dream child he then tried
possessing Alice's unborn baby but he
wound up reverting back to infancy and
was reabsorbed by his ghost mom all of
which brings us to Freddy's dead at the
final nightmare set years after the
previous films on a Biff Tannen asked
future where Freddy finally achieved his
goals the movie takes place in a spring
word the void of youth thanks to the
knife handed maniac by the time the
credits rolled Freddy was reunited with
his long-lost daughter who pulled him
into the physical world and gave him a
thorough stubbing sending Krueger to
hell once and for all
ish these days any brand friendly
fictional character worth their salt has
been revamped rebooted and reimagined at
least half a dozen times Freddy Krueger
managed to get a head start on the trend
for the decidedly bananas Wes Craven's
new nightmare
released in 1994 back when forth walls
were still considered to be generally
load-bearing new nightmare posited that
an embodiment of evil could be contained
within the essence of a fictional
character and that the concept of Freddy
Krueger had become the home of one such
entity within the film of this
supernatural force broke free of the
confines of the fictional world wreaking
havoc on the production of a proposed
new Nightmare on Elm Street entry and
attacking the real-world people involved
in creating the series she's been held
have pretty much asked Freddie in the
nightmare announced Reid serious but now
that the films have ended the genies out
of the bottle
bonkers totally and maybe a little less
relatable than a relatively
straightforward agent of ancient
nightmare demons the audience's have
become accustomed to a monster is only
as good as its over-the-top smackdowns
and Freddy Krueger has a decent history
of playing king of the hill with other
fictional freak shows the most famous of
these came in the form of 2003 s Freddy
vs. Jason their critically Pan's but
long awaited cross-promotional
extravaganza if things went just a
little bit differently Freddy would have
had a whole new fight on his own world
lead knife fans according to the
screenwriters on Freddy vs. Jason one
potential ending that was scrapped over
rights issues involved Krueger and Jason
and held together being taunted by
pinhead of their Hellraiser series
luckily enough for fans who felt like
there was beef left and squashed by the
crossover a sequel comic was released a
few years later and added one thing that
can mathematically only improve on is a
product sprinkled in liberally Bruce
Campbell the 2007 miniseries Freddy vs.
Jason versus ash is difficult not to
love out from the self-aware 90s and the
kind of a drag early 2000s came the Dark
Age of kriti all received two reboots
and lo there was 2010's a Nightmare on
Elm Street jumping in at the tail end of
a couple of years when superheroes
weren't quite 100% viable money printing
machines and nostalgia still seen like
the Hollywood team to beat The Nightmare
on Elm Street reboots had all of the
hallmarks of its time heavily colored
filtered the void of comic relief and
starring a lead actor who was probably
too good for the material it spoke its
truth Hey it seemed to say to the world
what if Freddy Krueger generally the
only person in these movies who seems to
be having a good time was just gross and
creepy and looks like a Gulf of fallout
3
dream and audiences responded with a
mighty who cares the movie was a
box-office disappointment and it somehow
managed to nab a lower Rotten Tomatoes
score from the great American cash grab
that was Freddy vs. Jason positive
aspects included some genuinely and
settling nightmare sequences less
defensible points in the film were
pretty much everything else check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one